el presidente de Estados Unidos
ha visitado el área de Fort Myers en
Florida donde hace justo una semana pasó
el huracán Ian dejando un panorama
devastador el mandatario ha visto cómo
se están llevando a cabo las tareas de
rescate que es ahora mismo la prioridad
al tiempo que se siguen sumando más
muertes por esta catástrofe ya hay más
de un centenar de víctimas mortales
confirmadas pero se teme que sean muchas
más ya que aún no se ha podido llegar a
algunos lugares a pie vayan ha venido
hasta Florida con un objetivo el de
mostrar el compromiso del Gobierno
Federal de destinar todos los recursos
que sean necesarios para reconstruir
esta zona cuanto antes también ha
prometido ayudas económicas para todos
los damnificados por el potente ciclón a
través de la agencia de manejo de
emergencias una visita Que obviamente
también tiene un trasfondo político y
más cuando la gestión del gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis
empieza a estar en dicho y es que
algunas voces críticas sostienen que no
se llevaron a cabo todos los protocolos
necesarios de seguridad para evacuar a
la población ya que muchos no Se tomaron
en serio los avisos de tormenta de
santis se ha defendido y ha dicho que se
cumplieron con todos los mecanismos pero
es que la gestión de esta crisis puede
tener consecuencias políticas y más
teniendo en cuenta que el nombre de ron
de santis cada vez suena con más fuerza
como posible candidato presidencial
republicano para las elecciones
generales de 2024 en Estados Unidos
además ha sido muy crítico con la
gestión de biden al frente de la Casa
Blanca por eso Muchos consideran que
dependiendo del trabajo que se haga
ahora en cuanto a la reconstrucción
puede beneficiar o perjudicar las
aspiraciones políticas de ambos